[Music]
[Applause]
right let me ask Peter shreer that one
of the host of NFL Network's good
morning football will Josh Allen make a
Super Bowl in his career feels like he's
getting further and further away as we
wake up this morning Dan good morning uh
I I put this out there you know Dan F
was a Hall of Fame
quarterback never played in a Super Bowl
Warren Moon was a Hall of Fame
I think Philip Rivers is going to the
Super Bowl uh to the Hall of Fame he
never played in Super sometimes that's
just how it is and you can have great
seasons and you can have great careers
and you can put up a lot of but if this
Bills team with the cards that they were
laid out at home against an underman
Chiefs team that hasn't been their best
with no Joe bur in the in the landscape
whatsoever the path was there path was
there and they're gone in the divisional
round again and the way Josh Allen plays
So Physical running so much I don't see
that in his 30s becoming an even greater
part of his game um I don't see his arm
strength getting better in his 30s and
I'm not sure this roster gets any better
with all the free agents they have it's
a cold pill to lose in a divisional
round for Bill's fans I think it's
particularly a cold pill because this
was Josh Allen at his all-time best
again last night and they're not going
to even make it to the championship game
yeah I feel good about the Texans future
I feel good about the Packers future I
don't know about the Buccaneers future
um and buffalo you know they're in
salary cap hell
so I don't feel great about Buffalo
moving forward I did pose this question
all right bill bellich is out there on
the open market if you're Buffalo would
you entertain bringing bill bich in back
into the division that he knows oh so
well what' you do then here's the thing
there's been no outside coaching hires
made yet so you're not so far behind the
eightball where it's like you know what
we got so far in the playoffs and at
this point to hire a coach we're gonna
be behind the belich hasn't hire been
hired by the Falcons it's a conversation
you can have on talk radio and we can do
it I don't know if Buffalo sees it as
Shawn mcdermitt's right there and this
wasn't a McDermot thing like gosh if you
are to make the case that they can't win
with McDermot you would say the offense
was awesome last night for Buffalo it
was the defense and the special teams
that let them down in the big spots but
feel like Sean still got that team um
but just as the Cowboys are bringing
back McCarthy saying we're right there I
feel like Buffalo's gonna bring back
mcder and say we're right there belich
though I didn't anticipate that question
that's a wild card and guess what in
today's NFL if Pula looked at it and
said you know what I'm not getting any
younger my quarterback's not getting any
younger I think Bel is a better Coach
I'm going to make a rash decision I
don't think anybody would say well no
you can't do that now I think Buffalo
fans are so upset and so starving for a
Victor and so starving for an
opportunity to get back to that Super
Bowl that anything is on the table at
this point can you uh reset the NFL head
coaching job market right now with
Harbaugh and bellich meeting with
Atlanta twice by the way nobody else has
interviewed Bill bellich no a't that
Strange greatest coach of all time and
nobody else has reached out yet how
surprising is that it's very surprising
and you know rael's interviewed for the
uh Vel went in and interviewed for the
Chargers job and when Vel got fired
everyone on in my world's like oh well
the line to hire Mike Vel will be around
the block I think all three of those
guys Harbaugh bich and Vel if you hire
them you are hiring a cult of
personality you are hiring this is how
it's done this is how I do it and this
is what I'm bringing now they could all
say in the interviews they're going to
be flexible and yeah know I'm cool with
you having your GM and your president
and all your different org chart members
and and oh no no yeah know I like what
we got going on here but the end of the
day those guys are made men and I don't
think Jim Harbaugh is leaving Michigan
to take direction from a different
general manager or hire a defensive
coordinator and offensive hasn't know
and in bich che's case gosh Rich McKay
is a lifer in this league and he's been
with the Falcons for years and I don't
think he's going anywhere and Terry
fontino was a recently hot hire from the
Saints as a GM and he's going through
this his third year and he was he
brought came in with Arthur Smith I
don't think he's going anywhere and I
wonder if you know what it's a little
easier if we just hire a Rahim Morris or
an airo evero or if belich che's looking
at it and saying I don't want to be
taking orders they having to weigh in
with Rich McKay and and Terry Fontano
I'm I'm bill belich so I always think of
corporate structure and what you're
bringing in when you hire these bigname
hires because Harbaugh doesn't just come
as Jim Harbaugh coach Jim Harbaugh comes
with with the whole Jim Harbaugh machine
and you got to kind of give him that
power fascinating that neither one of
those guys have been hired it's
fascinating that belich interviewed
twice with the Falcons yeah but also you
have the Chargers situation and you do
have you know the one team that has a
quarterback in place uh how desirable is
that job and how do you think that plays
out with LA yeah I thought from the
start that was Harbaugh's job to lose it
felt like it made a lot of sense he's
got San Diego ties which isn't Los
Angeles where they play but when he
coached at the University of San Diego
and he's got a history of all right if
there's an urgency to win bring me in
we'll win now over the next couple years
you might not like everything about it
and I might turn some of the people off
but we're gonna win and I feel like in
that market with a desire to be relevant
with a desire to get the most out of
Justin Herbert you bring in the
quarterback Whisperer Jim Harbaugh and
you make it happen but it hasn't
happened yet the one that's looming that
I haven't heard his name mentioned and
he hasn't interviewed Pete Carol in
Southern California would be a monster
monster needle mover and this would be
one of those where you're talking about
stealing some of the market share from
USC and UCL I agree I agree I'm with you
on that wants to coach still yeah dude
Pete wants to coach and I think Pete
would come in with energy and it's
Orange County it's Manhattan Beach this
is where Pete Carol lives and yet
there's been no reports of even a
conversation with Pete Carol from the
Spanos family so Harbaugh's Big Splash
but Pete Carol you're talking about all
the things you want to check off the box
as far as in that market being relevant
and what he can bring I think Pete Carol
would be an interesting one too he's
Peter shreer host of NFL Network's good
morning football that's Monday through
Friday at 7 Eastern on NFL Network
assistant coaches in the playoffs or
coaching candidates in the playoffs can
they interview during the week yeah no
now it's now it's it's it's kind of
locked in now for the guys who are
remaining so you saw that uh Mike
McDonald interviewed during the the the
last week this week it was time for a
lot of those teams that were in the Wild
Card round to interview and the one that
I love was Ben Johnson on Saturday
interviewed for three different teams
virtually three different teams before
the game of his life and then actually
delivered had an amazing game plan and
the Lions took care of business uh but
there's all sorts of different
conversations happening right now with
these guys who are still in I think it
kind of pauses for the guys who are
still remaining um but all the others
can interview for sure and then you talk
about coordinators and that's a little
lesser on the on the the dial but like
what are the Eagles going to do they
what what are the Patriots going to do
who are they hiring which Rod mail all
that is now happening and there's so
many conversations and a lot of these
are with search firms so teams will hire
an outside search firm whether it be
Mike Ford who's running things in
Carolina right now or you've got your
corn Ferry and your other Jed you know
they've got these names and these guys
put it all together and they work with
these teams and they're the ones talking
with these coaches and saying would you
be interested can we set you up with the
meeting so fascinating time but yeah it
seems like conference champion ship week
like let's dial ourselves in here will
an an established coach coach
Carolina I think they're gonna go young
I think they're gonna go away from the
bellich Vel Harbaugh tree and I think
it's gonna be more of a younger coach
that I think now look I might they might
hire raheim Morris today they might hire
zir evero today but I think from what
I've heard that a lot of these
conversations was what with David terer
and some of these coach candidates what
can you do with Bryce young and what can
you get out of Bryce young and if that's
the case sounds like an offensive coach
and I think they've got a great list of
young offensive coaches who have
interviewed with them and whether it be
slowick who just got exited in Houston
whether it be uh Ben Johnson who didn't
interview last year but has taken the
meeting this year and then you go with
Dave Canales who is kind of this wild
card name who is the Tampa Bay offensive
coordinator who no one was talking about
before the season Buccaneers got a lot
out of Baker Mayfield um maybe maybe he
a surprise pick that they could hire in
Carolina as well your Super Bowl pick
today is who the same Super Bowl pick I
made in September when I did it on our
show and I have been had it pinned on my
Twitter I will not abandon it because
it's just you just gotta ride with a
team that you got what's the term you
dance with the guy that took you
whatever it is I or the girl whatever it
is hey whatever it is that's true um
I've got the cheats beating the 49ers in
the Super Bowl Chiefs against the Niners
in the Super Bowl I got the Chiefs
winning you know I I said this to start
the show I as strange as it's going to
sound I think Patrick Mahomes is
underrated talk about it I agree I mean
it's he's awesome well you never ever he
was awesome on Saturday night in the
minus 30 against the Dolphins on peacock
he was amazing yes but I think we get to
the point where you get to a certain
level and then we take you for granted
that you're a great story
and then all of a sudden we take you for
granted we like Giannis with the Bucks
you know we we kind of take him for
granted uh you know the Joker we're
going to take him for granted in the NBA
like there's certain players that you
just go yeah oh that's right yeah he's
great I'll say this I think in a
different era Charles Barkley probably
wins a championship and so does Carl
Malone and guess what Patrick Ying
probably gets ring maybe C maybe CDE
Drexler
too uh I don't want to put the pull a
the C before the horse and all that
because Lamar's the real deal and Joe
burrow has beaten Mahomes granted
Mahomes up 213 at home and burrow beat
him it's happened but I think we're
we're in an era now and I think instead
of always trying to anoint the next
maybe we should appreciate who the
current is well I look at the Ravens and
everybody has looked in One Direction
and that's been the quarterback that
defense Patrick Mahomes will earn a trip
to the Super Bowl if you win on the road
in Buffalo and you beat Bal Baltimore in
Baltimore there's no questions then
about well every home game in the
playoffs you know hey that that Buffalo
defense was down about eight guys they
were they were they were on fumes at the
end uh this Ravens defense fully healthy
awesome and they just suffocated CJ
strout in a way that we haven't seen all
season they are legit and they are
really well coached uh he's gonna earn
it all 60 minutes he's going to earn it
but as I said on good morning football
Friday when I was the only person on the
network I think who took the Chiefs to
win uh I cannot pick against Patrick
momes not because I picked them
beforeand but because I still believe in
Patrick Mahomes like I don't in my head
I don't Envision in a situation where
he's gonna Wilt in a moment uh before I
let you go do you think they change the
fumble out of the end zone yeah I would
imagine there's real outcry and I
actually speak to a lot of defensive
people who hate that there such outcry
over it but uh remember Ron Rivera a
couple years back when the Browns had it
happen in Hollywood um I forget
Hollywood what was the name or 8
Hollywood Higgins fumbled it through the
back of the Enzo and everyone the same
outcry this morning of like you got to
change that rule Ron Rivera is like
everyone knows that rule you gotta
protect the ball around the end like
it's the one rule that actually benefits
the defense and actually isn't just but
I think there's some real outcry over it
and it's just too punitive so I would
imagine it's goingon to be voted on and
I think there's been a real push to
change that rule well I think Tony Romo
even said like you get down there you
can't try to extend the play because you
do run the risk of fumbling the ball out
of the end Zone but I know we've said it
for a couple of years usually it takes a
moment in the playoffs for for change to
happen and yeah but the Chiefs won
though so it's not this thing like
you're right you're right had they lost
had they lost then then we might be
looking at that as oh they're definitely
gonna change Dan had they lost I would
have said in the morning what the hell
you doing and giving it to mle
Hardman touched the ball twice on the
turf twice he was cut by the Jets what
are we
doing just ran again yeah there's only
so much you can change you you can't
change how he I'm right I'm I'm right
there with you I'm like oh why am I why
are you giving him the ball just give it
to P yes uh hey safe travels this
weekend to Baltimore thanks for joining
us you're the man dude thank you so much
for having me on as always that's Peter
shreer he's uh one of the host of good
morning football Monday through Friday
at 7 a.m. eastern on NFL Network